et c'est lors du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus
à la une ce soir rien ne va plus entre
le mali et la france les accords de
défense bilatéraux ne tiennent plus
selon bamako les autorités de transition
évoque les insuffisances graves de la
france et les attentes à sa souveraineté
le quai d'orsay dénonce de son côté une
décision injustifiée spécialiste des
questions de sécurité en afrique me
régale et bagayoko est notre invité
et human rights watch dénonce les
exactions commises par les mercenaires
russes en centrafrique un rapport de
l'oued j'ai fait état de civils torture
et d'autres tuer en toute impunité les
groupes paramilitaires avaient été
recrutés pour venir à bout des rebelles
qui menaçait le régime de bangui
et puis c'est aujourd'hui la zone et à
mondiale de la liberté de la presse nous
ferons un point sur les difficultés
rencontrées par les journalistes sur le
continent lois répressives en simulation
ou encore prolifération des flous le ils
ont établi par rsf il est mitigé
l'annoncé a été faite lundi soir à la
télévision malienne le colonel abdoulaye
maïga porte parole du gouvernement
annonce la rupture des accords de
défense qui lient le mali à la france en
deux accords encadrons pour l'un barque
à l'autre à tout va et un accord de
coopération en matière de défense bamako
fait plusieurs reproches à paris
'l'annonce unilatérale de son retrait
militaire la violation de son espace
aérien mais également l'absence de
réponse à ces demandes de révision du
traité de coopération paris a dénoncé ce
mardi cette décision des autorités
maliennes et pour bien prendre la mesure
de cette décision nous en une semaine en
ligne avec l niagalén bakayoko bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes à la tête de la snl
l'afrique and security secteur networks
spécialiste donc des questions de
sécurité sur le continent ma première
question cette rupture des accords de
défense signifie tels que les troupes
françaises encore présente au mali sont
désormais illégal
la situation à mon avis plus complexe
que celle pas parce que différents
accords ont été dénoncés d'une part les
status of trust
qu'on appelle sofia avec un chrono de
2020 et de 2013 qui réglemente la
présence des troupes étrangères dont
françaises en territoire malien d'autre
part l'accord de coopération qui porte
sur les formations les entraînements et
les coopérations en matière de
renseignement ce deuxième accord ne sera
pas particulièrement impliquant s'il est
suspendu s'il est dénoncée dans la
mesure où des dents et déjà il y a arrêt
de la coopération en revanche la
dénonciation des deux sofa peut avoir de
grandes conséquences d'une part pour les
conditions de retrait des forces barkan
est à kouba d'autres pas pour le soutien
apporté par barkan à la misma mais aussi
à terme pour le redéploiement l'arrêt
articulations actuel du dispositif
français vers le niger alors la france a
fait savoir qu'elle poursuivrait son
retrait militaire en bon ordre comme
prévu dans les prochains mois face à
l'insistance de bamako pourquoi paris
n'accélère pas le retrait des troupes
françaises du mali
tout simplement parce que d'un point de
vue opérationnel la manoeuvre est
extrêmement délicate il s'agit à la fois
de ne pas se laisser attaquer par les
groupes djihadistes qui reste le
principal adversaire sur le terrain des
forces françaises et d'autre part de ne
pas se trouver dans une situation de
porte à faux avec les autorités
maliennes qui pourrait amener à des
incidents militaires sur le terrain donc
aujourd'hui il me sens très difficile
pour la force barca d'accélérer son
retrait qui est prévu pour l'été 2022
est-ce que ça va compliquer les
opérations militaires anti terroriste
menée dans la région du sahel avec donc
cette interdiction de survoler mali oui
indéniablement et cela renvoie à
justement ce redéploiement auquel je
faisais référence
il ya eu des affrontements extrêmement
violents entre l'état islamique au grand
sahara qui est l'un des principaux
djihadistes combattue par la force
barkan d'une part et d'autre part des
groupes signataires de l'accord de paix
notamment le gars tia et le msa dans la
zone des trois frontières
il sera absolument fondamental pour la
force qui rend partent en place rats
barkan de manière beaucoup plus discrète
d'être en mesure d'intervenir sur cet
espace des trois frontières et la
dénonciation notamment de ce sofa va
être extrêmement problématique à mon
avis d'un point de vue opérationnel
nyaga les bagayoko est ce que le divorce
est totalement apte et entre paris et
bamako est ce qu'il subsiste des voies
de dialogue
le divorce à mon avis est assez
irrémédiable et on voit chaque semaine
de nouveaux épisodes qui aggrave la
situation aujourd'hui
l'affrontement entre la france et le
mali se déroule sur trois terrains qui
sont d'une part le terrain diplomatique
d'autre part le terrain informationnel
comme on l'a vu à la faveur de la
découverte du charnier à gossip et enfin
aujourd'hui sur le terrain juridique il
est à souhaiter qu'il n'y ait pas de
dérapage militaire mais la surenchère
apparaît comme extrêmement périlleuse il
faut cependant se rendre compte qu'il ya
aussi un certain nombre d'acteurs très
importants comme par exemple le conseil
national de transition au mali qui ont
l'air de rechercher une voie plus
apaisée envers certains acteurs internet
aux acteurs partenaires peut-être il
s'agit de l'une des voies pour faire en
sorte que les relations franco malienne
entre dans une période un peu plus
apaisé alors il ya eu une réunion
informelle à huis clos ce mardi au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu à la
demande de la russie
le groupe paramilitaire bruce wagner
serait déjà présent au mali est-ce que
moscou pourrait à terme récupérer ces
accords de coopération militaire
il y a d'ores et déjà des accords de
coopération militaire qui existe entre
le mali et la russie et qui d'ailleurs
ne s'appelle pas de l'arrivée au pouvoir
des autorités civiles et militaires
actuelles on sait que sous le président
ib cas aussi bien que sous le président
amadou toumani touré des accords de
coopération notamment en termes
d'équipements auprès de l'armée russe
ont été conclus il est effectivement
assez vraisemblable que cette
coopération se
approfondissent la question qui se pose
est de savoir sous quelles modalités
les autorités maliennes continue de nier
la présence de la société militaire
privée wagner alors même que le
président poutine lui-même et le
ministre des affaires étrangères lavrov
sur une chaîne vitale yens hier ont
confirmé sa présence au mali est-ce que
c'est sous traitants russes pourront
être les principaux acteurs de la mise
en oeuvre de la coopération entre le
mali et la ainsi c'est toute la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
inégalée à bagayoko pour votre analyse
rappelle que vous êtes à la tête de la
ssr spécialistes dont des questions de
sécurité sur le continent et on en vient
justement aux agissements des
mercenaires russes de wagner en
centrafrique et sont accusés par human
rights watch d'avoir commis des
exactions et les preuves s'accumulent
l'eau angie a recueilli et des dizaines
de témoignages de victimes de proches ou
de témoins de ces exactions commises par
les paramilitaires de wagner des
meurtres et des tortures perpétrés en
toute impunité depuis 2010 9 nous avons
interviewé lewis much directeur pour
l'afrique centrale chez human rights
watch et il est revenu sur les
événements commis à bossangoa en juillet
dernier
depuis 2000 19 new york human rights
watch nous avons documenté plusieurs
crimes faits par les militaires liées à
la russe tout d'abord ces crimes
manifester comme les actes et un jeune
arbitre r et le torture mais en 2021
nous avons toujours pu monter une
crainte très grave
exécutions sommaires qui est lui un nom
de bossangoa au menu deux pays dans ce
cas il ya au moins douze personnes mais
peut-être 13 qui étaient tués par les
forces les ailes russe ces gens étaient
sans armes ces gens étaient ils ont
obligé les gens de coucher par terre
avant de les exécuter nous avons parlé
avec les témoins et les gens de
l'endroit qui encore fermé le fait noah
chi minh weight watchers nous avons
plusieurs questions par rapport de
militaires russes qui se trouve toujours
en rca depuis un bon moment donc ils
sont là pour croix jusqu'à maintenant
nous sommes jamais vu les documents
pour le document date rimont pour
inviter les militaires russes d'aller en
rca mais la chose plus important pour
nous c'est de lancer un appel aux
nouveaux de la gouvernement de
centrafrique c'est leur devoir de lancer
une vraie inquiète par rapportent les
actes et tueries qui se trouvent sur
leur sol
par les forces étrangers qui étaient
invités à eux mêmes le gouvernement
centrafricain
ils ont fait par centaines les violences
jihadistes dans le sahel des habitants
du mali ou encore du burkina faso ont
trouvé refuge dans le camp de ouallam
dans l'ouest du niger la situation
devient de plus en plus difficile à
gérer pour les autorités nigériennes et
ce mardi les réfugiés ont reçu la visite
du secrétaire général des nations unies
antonio guterres a appelé à un
renforcement de l'aide internationale
les précisions de notre correspondant à
un rôle gérard qui s'est rendu dans le
camp de wuala
sur les treize départements de la région
de tillabéri 8 sont directement impactés
par les violences perpétrées par groupes
armés les populations fuient et de plus
en plus de déplacés internes viennent
s'installer autour de la ville de
ouallam dans le nord de cette région
justement de tillabéri en plus de cela
la hausse des attaques terroristes au
mali voisin depuis le début de l'année
2022 contribue à tendre la situation à
la frontière entre les deux pays en mars
dernier en moins de trois semaines c'est
plus de 18000 maliens qui ont fui vers
le niger du jamais vu depuis dix ans d
arriver si soudaine que même les
réponses d'urgence apportée par les ong
est apportée par l'état nigérien ne
peuvent pas garantir tous les besoins
vous là sans elle n'appelle pour le
renforcer particulièrement les
structures sanitaires éducatifs
hydraulique de ouallam à faire découvrir
les besoins des différentes populations
antonio guterres est ce lui tente de
mobiliser le soutien de la communauté
internationale autour de la question
nigérienne en ce faisant je cite avocats
des demandes du président mohamed bazoum
en ce sens je termine
la visite au niger
avec les populations martyrisées douala
les populations déplacées des villages
attaqués par les terroristes dans la
région et avec les réfugiés venus du
mali
et je profite de cette occasion pour
dire à la communauté internationale
qu'il faut appuyer à fond le niger selon
l'organisation des nations unies la
réponse humanitaire prévue en 2022 pour
le niger n'est pour l'instant financé
qu'à hauteur de 9% alors que le pays
traverse une triple crise sécuritaire
alimentaire écologique en somalie ce une
attaque des shebab fait des dizaines de
morts les combattants islamistes
lourdement armés ont lancé leur assaut
très tôt ce mardi prenant pour cible une
malle une base militaire de la force de
maintien de la paix de l'union africaine
cela s'est passé près du village de cils
baraf au nord-est de mogadiscio
les précisions de notre correspondante
dans la région elodie cousin attaque a
commencé un peu avant l'aube ce mardi
matin par deux attentats suicide avant
de se poursuivre par des combattants
hier de la base des habitants disent
avoir entendu de fortes explosions ainsi
que des tirs si l'union africaine n'a
pour le moment pas commenté cette
attaque elle a été revendiqué par les
islamistes shebab qui disent avoir tué
173 soldats burundais et en avoir
capturé d'autres mais aucun chiffre
officiel n'a pour le moment été donnée
même s'il attaque a été confirmée par
les autorités locales et que le ministre
des affaires étrangères a indiqué sur
twitter qu'il y avait eu des pertes
civiles alors il s'agit de la première
attaque majeure contre une base de
l'union africaine depuis que sa mission
a changé de nom le mois dernier elle
intervient en plein processus électoral
est en pleine lutte de pouvoir entre
l'actuel président et son premier
ministre
les partenaires internationaux se sont
dits très préoccupés par les différents
retards qu'il y avait eu dans le
processus électoral et il pense que et
bien tous ces problèmes
distrait le gouvernement dans son combat
contre les shebab à reporters sans
frontières a publié ce mardi son rapport
annuel sur la liberté de la presse et en
afrique le constat est mitigé si
certains pays montrent des signes
d'ouverture médiatique des lois
liberticides la prolifération des
enfants que sur les réseaux ont
contribué à saper la crédibilité des
journalistes et à porter atteinte au
droit à l'information
les explications de laurent père pêcheur
entre ouverture et répression en 2022 la
liberté de la presse reste extrêmement
polarisé en afrique vous avez tout en
haut du classement dans le top 20
d'ailleurs deux pays comme les
seychelles et la namibie d'ailleurs
c'est une première qui est de pays dans
le top 20 où la liberté de la presse est
plutôt garantie et vous avez à l'autre
extrémité des pays comme djibouti ou
l'erythrée où il n'y a absolument aucune
liberté de la presse les journalistes
sont soit en prison soit en exil il ya
aucun média privé indépendant reporters
sans frontières note qu'une récente
vague de lois répressives
par exemple au mali au bénin et au
burkina faso ont porté atteinte au droit
à l'information
l'organisation dénonce également la
prolifération des rumeurs et des intox
sur les réseaux sociaux qui ont
contribué à saper la crédibilité du
journalisme sur le continent mais dans
certains pays où la presse a longtemps
été muselés elle constate un début
d'ouverture comme au burundi qui
enregistre un bond en avant de 40 places
ou en guinée qui progresse de 25 places
malgré un récent coup d'état même si des
progrès restent à faire selon les
syndicats de journalistes
c'est au niveau des discours qui a eu un
changement des assurances données à la
presse pour dire que vous serrez
indépendant mais dans les faits a encore
des soucis surtout que la loi sur le
droit d'accès à l'information publique
n'est pas encore respectée parmi les
mauvais élèves on compte l'erythrée et
djibouti et le soudan mais aussi
l'egypte relégué à la 168e place
mondiale tandis qu'au maghreb la tunisie
enregistre un profond recul sous la
présidence de kaïs sayed mais reste loin
devant ses voisins marocains et
algériens
de l'afrique je vous retrouve dans moins
d'une heure pour une nouvelle édition à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]